(light playful music)
- [Narrator] This is the Spider tortoise.
These little guys are so
endangered that scientists say
that they could completely
vanish in the next 15 years.
The Spider tortoise is hard to find.
For one, they're tiny.
One of the smallest known land-turtles,
rarely reaching more than
six inches in length.
Another reason, they only
inhabit a tiny sliver
of Madagascar's southwestern coast.
Their name comes from the
web-like patterns on their shells.
During the dry season, they
bury themselves in the sand,
and reemerge when it rains
to feed on leaves, roots, and insects.
Just because they're tiny
doesn't mean they're young.
They're estimated to live
up to 70 years in the wild.
These little guys are up against a lot.
The largest concern is that
they are still hunted locally
for food, but the illegal pet
trade, and shrinking habitat,
are all threats to their survival.
This is the Spider tortoise.
(light playful music)